[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7 8 et
d'où nous sommes le vendredi 7 octobre
une émission pour revenir sur
l'actualité de la semaine voici les
titres l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines organisée aujourd'hui un
colloque sur les violences familiales
chercheurs spécialistes et
professionnels ont notamment évoqué la
prise en charge des victimes alors que
le taux de plaintes plafonne à 15% en
cas de violences familiales
durant cette émission daniel guerreau
président de l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes sera notre invité fil
rouge avec lui nous parlerons du salon
de l'automobile de la piétonisation des
voies sur berge rive droite à paris ou
encore de la hausse envisagée de la taxe
essence en ile de france et puis bien
sûr vous savez dans cette émission le
reste de l'actualité du département avec
la nouvelle permanence du parti les
républicains a inauguré ou une opération
de sensibilisation au handicap en
entreprise à montigny le bretonneux
non on ouvre ce journal avec ces images
celle d'une sculpture parti aux états
unis cette sculpture c'est celle de
l'artiste saint quentinois elle nicolas
sanhes trois mètres de haut et quatre
mètres cinquante de long et une tonne de
métal l'oeuvre est parti direction miami
aux états unis pour rejoindre une
collection privée nous avons d'ailleurs
rencontré l'artiste il y a quelques
jours juste avant le départ à l'heure
des retouches on les écoute
puis un peu de brouillard ce qu'on
appelle enfin quand tu passes à la
peinture
sont les petites autos mais la partie
culture qu'ils viennent se coller au
dernier moment et donc son côté un petit
peu abrasif donc la lèvre
et
ce cas permettre aux vernis d'avoir une
meilleure accroche c'est assez plaisant
parce que la fois je l'amène aujourd'hui
je travaille sur une aire objets
fabriqués qui n'appartient plus et je
suis en train de la deûle à refaire une
beauté avant qu'elle qu'elle a quitté
définitivement
l'atelier c'est une sculpture qui fait
de ces mini d'acier avec une géométrie
qui m'est propre
dans l'actualité également de ce
vendredi un colloque sur les violences
familiales organisées par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines professionnels et spécialistes
se sont réunis aujourd'hui en salle du
conseil communautaire pour évoquer
notamment la prise en charge des
victimes chaque année en france un peu
plus de deux cent mille femmes se
déclarent victimes de violences
conjugales à un reportage d'haussmann
avant de re des
chaque année deux cent mille familles
déclarent être victimes de violences
conjugales pourtant le taux de plaintes
quelle que soit la violence est très
faible elle n'est seulement que de 10%
un problème que des spécialistes
souhaitent résoudre la violence fait
peur elle tétanise il y à un phénomène
de sidération
et du coup ce qui entraîne
une difficulté pour pourparlers pour
laisser notre devoir d'aider à la
libération de la parole pour pouvoir
positionner la loi et ce combat contre
les violences familiales est une
priorité dans l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines il est même inscrit
dans le contrat 2015-2020 de la ville le
but aider les familles communiquer sur
les organismes qui peuvent leur venir en
aide aujourd'hui l'agglomération reste
sur ses missions d'animation de
coordination faire connaître les
ressources du territoire auprès des
professionnels auprès du grand public
aujourd'hui c'est ça la ce sont les
principales missions de de
l'agglomération une trentaine
d'intervenants et environ 120 personnes
ont participé à l'événement plusieurs
colloques seront organisées tout au long
de l'année
[Musique]
et pour aborder maintenant le reste de
l'actualité un invité nous ont rejoints
sur le plateau daniel guerreau le
président de l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes bonsoir oui bonsoir
alors évidemment avec vous on va évoquer
toutes les actualités autour des
transports et de l'automobile elles sont
nombreuses à commencer par un sujet sur
lequel vous avez pris position récemment
et qui froisse de nombreux élus
franciliens et notamment dans les
yvelines la piétonisation des voies sur
berge rive droite à paris le projet a
été voté définitivement en par la mairie
de paris il ya quelques jours c'était
fin septembre un projet qui exclut donc
de fait les véhicules le long de la
seine seront à parcours de 3 km vous
êtes-vous farouchement opposé à ce
projet dit dites nous pourquoi oui
d'abord nous sommes une association
nationale mais ce sujet essentiellement
parisien et ile de france plus que sympa
que l'ile-de-france a entraîné chez nous
un nombre de message extrêmement
important donc ça veut dire que ce sujet
passionne bon nombre d'automobilistes
d'île de france parce que paris quand il
décide de fermer une voie qui irrigue
l'ensemble la capitale et de l'île de
france c'est tout l'ile-de-france qui
est impactée donc paris
finalement pose d'abord à ses citoyens
et encore parce que finalement sur quoi
se base la mairie de paris pour
l'argument est écologique l'armement
technologique mois il va falloir la
pollution il va falloir que l'on
m'explique comment occupant une voie est
donc en créant des bouchons importants
ont diminué la pollution je suis
peut-être idiot que j'arrive pas à
comprendre pour vous est ce que cette
mesure aussi est-ce qu'on peut aller
aussi loin que ça est ce que c'est une
atteinte à la liberté des franciliens
est ce qu'on peut aller on peut se
permettre de dire ça est-ce que selon
vous le fait de prendre cette décision
la c1 peut atteindre la liberté des
francine je saute liberté de circuler je
sais qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'associations et en particulier celle
des maires franciliens qui se propose
d'attaquer la mairie de paris sur ce
thème de la liberté 1 je connais bien
monsieur françois pelletant quel
président des maires du nord france
d'ailleurs nous sommes associés à son
action et nous avons été les premiers à
demander j'ai même sollicité madame
pécresse en disant il faut absolument
que vous soyez décisionnaire dans ce
type
co décisionnaire dans ce type de déchets
on voulait que la région prenne louis la
part de sa part du gâteau dans le débat
participe à ce débat donne son avis bien
sûr parce que cette voie irrigue non
seulement paris mais l'ensemble de
l'îlot ce moment j'ai des gens qui
parlent de d'est en ouest et d'ouest en
est donc d'île de france qui traverse
paris concède voilà pour circuler et
d'un seul coup on la coupe donc ça il ya
un impact sur l'ensemble la circulation
autour de paris la mer la maire de paris
anne hidalgo la maire socialiste dit que
c'est un projet qu'elle porte quand
intel était adjoint au maire aussi
depuis quinze ans que ce n'est pas
nouveau que tout le monde était au
courant qu'elle voulait le faire
notamment dans ce qu'on va me municipal
est-ce que ça a été évoqué par exemple
avec une association comme vous alors
elle l'a fait toute seule on a toujours
été très peu concerté c'est vrai que ça
commençait sous delanoë cette volonté de
bouter hors de paris la voiture et leur
concept pour y arriver est de créer un
certain nombre de freins la voiture ou
d'interdiction ça veut dire de dégoûter
des gens de venir à paris il ya même
l'adjoint nationale chose qui qui dit
que si on crée des bouchons il ya
seulement deux voitures qui vont finir
par s'évaporer on aime bien ce concept
mais entre temps ce sont les parisiens
qui
déguste la cij et j'ose m'exprimer ainsi
parce qu'il ya de moins en moins de
voitures à paris de plus en plus de
bouchons d'ailleurs sous delanoë on a
déjà commencé par détruire un tiers des
parkings ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui en
permanence vous avez une voix de
voitures sur 10 qui tourne pour chercher
un parking voyez donc elles polluent ya
une politique de la mairie de paris qui
est mise en place soit disant pour
améliorer la qualité de l'air et qui
crée plus de pollution et est-ce que
aussi l'idée de pousser du coup les gens
à apprendre les transports avec ce type
de mesure puisque on ferme des routes
les poussières pour les transports vous
n'y croyez pas non plus cet argument là
sauf quand vous venez des yvelines par
exemple vous n'avez pas les moyens de
vous rendre son pari selon nous est
alors sans la voiture déjà nous ne
sommes pas pour tout automobile c'est
pas parce qu'on s'appelle car nous on se
glisse mais nous nous sommes pour la
complémentarité une offre complémentaire
ça veut dire où pourrait très bien
organisé des parkings gratuits aux
portes de paris les gens laissent pas
leurs voitures et pourrait prendre des
transports en commun présenté il
faudrait organiser cela avant
d'interdire mais là on met la charrue
avant les boeufs on commence par
interdite après dit on verra peut être à
faire des tramways est organisée voyez
donc c'est c'est une politique un peu de
gribouille qui n'apporterait rien en
terme de pollution qui gêne tout le
monde est en gros c'est pour quelques
milliers de privilégiés ont pourri la
vie de millions d'automobilistes en ile
de france maintenant que le projet est
lancé puisqu'il était votée fin
septembre le 26 septembre précisément
quels sont vos moyens de recours est ce
que vous espérez que la mairie de paris
fasse clairement machine en arrière
alors déjà la grogne est important on a
vu une manifestation organisée nous on
était aussi supporters de cette
manifestation organisée par d'après le
président des maires d'île de france
monsieur pelletant maire de linars et
nous avons soutenu cette manifestation
vous avait même appelé je dirais les
élus à faire entendre leur voix et puis
en dernier recours on pourra aussi
peut-être attaqué s'est arrêté là pour
entrave à la liberté il ya sur le texte
qui peuvent qu'ils peuvent je dirais
permettent d'attaquer l'amérique paye
sur ce sujet clairement 40 millions
d'automobilistes n'est pas on va dire
anti écolo ou anti environnement puisque
c'est ce que certains vos détracteurs
peuvent parfois le mot pas redire par ci
par là vous n'êtes vous pas forcément
pour le tout auto nous absolue moment on
n'est pas pour le tout autour mais nous
sommes je dis souvent mais à mes
détracteurs qui sont parisiens et
souvent et écologistes bobos parisiens
paris n'est pas la france n'est pas même
pas l'ile-de-france donc pour faire en
sorte que vous ayez votre confort vous
aller embêter et créer des problèmes à
l'ensemble des franciliens c'est pas
normal c'est pour ça qu'on avait demandé
à la région qu'elle que la région soit
impliqué d'ailleurs je disais il ya un
peu plus de quinze jours dans dans le
journal de dimanche que madame pécresse
proposait un plan anti bush on prive de
france parce que plus de bouchons pire
de pollution plus de temps perdu ça
coûte beaucoup d'argent alors pendant
que madame pécresse propose un plan anti
bush au vous avez la mairie de paris qui
propose un plan bouchaud et qu'il
aggrave chaque année il n'y a pas de
coordination entre par l'activité
territoriales je voudrais vous faire
réagir maintenant sur une autre
problématique c'est
la sirc l'interdiction circulation
excusez-moi des véhicules les plus
anciens depuis le 1er juillet à paris
les véhicules immatriculés avant 1997
n'ont plus droit de de circuler en
semaine entre 8h et 20h là aussi vous
êtes contre ce projet le mans et
pourquoi mais nan parce que cet argument
là aussi parce que c'est les anciens
véhicules qui polluent le plus mais
finalement qu'est ce que l'on fait par
cette mesure on essaie d'empêcher les
gens modestes de rouler et qui n'ont pas
forcément d'autres solutions où il ya
même des parisiens nous on a été moyen
âge précis d'une dame qui nous
appelaient redisant j'ai 70 ans j'ai une
voiture qui a à kilométrage encore
correcte elle est bien entretenu et les
dames en 97 tous les mercredis je dois à
l'égard des méprises au fond dans
l'essonne comment je fais j'ai ma soeur
qu'à 75 gens qui a du mal à marcher je
dois l'amener sur le caveau familial
comment je fais il ya tant de problèmes
comme ça et ces gens qui prennent des
décisions nos élites ne sont pas dans la
vraie vie donc c'est un vrai problème et
est-ce qu'on veut aussi repoussé tous
ces pauvres dans le métro sachant que
tous les enquêtes que vous avez pas
apparaître comme moi dans le métro et
entre deux et dix fois plus de
particules fines que dans la rue et
j'aimerais vous faire réagir sur une
dernière actualité récente c'est la
hausse très probable de la taxe de
consommation des produits énergétiques
concrètement c'est la taxe sur l'essence
le projet de loi finances 2017 prévoit
de l'augmenter pour participer au
financement des transports franciliens
et notamment du pass navigo à tarif
unique ça représenterait plus un vague
lille 65 centimes pour le gazoil 1,77
pour l'essence que vous inspire une
nouvelle fois cette disposition qui
n'est pas encore voté un je le précise
au parlement exactement bon vin une fois
de plus on essaie de prendre l'argent
dans la poche des automobilistes et
c'est assez souvent parce que déjà
l'automobiliste qui a qui paient
beaucoup pour mes lacets pour développer
les transports les moderniser mais c'est
leur donne raison cette fois ci ou ça
peut profiter le problème dans le futur
aux automobilistes qui pourrait du coup
se retourner vers les transports le
problème qui est local a eu à faire face
à madame pécresse c'est que quand elle
était arrivée il y avait le prédécesseur
qui lui avait laissé le tarif bas sur le
patch indique donc qu'elle avait un
déficit d'à peu près 450 millions au
niveau de la stif les transports le
syndicat des transports va la france
donc il a bien fallu trouver de l'argent
donc on a été voir pour négocier que
monsieur valls valls sont le complément
lui a dit a qu'une solution c'est
d'augmenter
l'accès la taxe sur les carburants voilà
donc que je pense qu'elle a accepté nous
ne sommes pas forcément très favorable
parce que souvent on demanda thomis de
financer pour des transports qu'il ne
prend pas de lui même mary japonais
prendre dans le futur oui mais déjà on
va avoir en et de france la taxe la plus
importante sur le sur le carburant donc
nous sommes pas très contents avec cette
mesure quand même dans l'actualité
également cette semaine il y avait
françois hollande en déplacement dans
les yvelines le président de la
république a s'est rendu à médan pour
inaugurer la réouverture de la maison
zola intégralement restauré il a rendu
hommage à l'écrivain auteur du célèbre
article j'accuse son perte de vue la
campagne présidentielle alors l'anguille
sur des images de nos confrères d'ign
une première c'est aux côtés de sa
ministre de la culture audrey azoulay
que françois hollande a inauguré hier la
réouverture de la maison d'emile zola
fermé pour travaux depuis 2011
l'écrivain avait pu s'offrir cette
demeure grâce au succès de son roman
l'assommoir dans une allocution de près
d'une demi heure le président a rappelé
les combat humaniste de l'écrivain
mentionnant à plusieurs reprises
l'espoir qu'il avait nourri toute sa
bulle même dans la nuit la plus sombre
lui toujours une espérance même dans le
grenache d'une machinerie infernale
il suffit d'une voix une seule pour
changer le cours des choses et le destin
des hommes une perspective que le
président pourrait bien souhaité pour
lui-même à quelques mois de la fin de
son mandat en conclusion comme un écho à
son propre parcours
il a tenu à rappeler l'essence même de
tout combat politique voilà notre
responsabilité face à l'histoire de pas
s'abandonner à la fatalité à la facilité
avoir le courage de faire le choix
justes qui n'est pas toujours le plus
populaire ou le plus gratifiant d'autres
personnalités invitées ont aussi rendu
hommage au grand homme
en prenant justement fait et cause dans
l' affaire dreyfus il a donné ses
lettres de noblesse et les lettres de
noblesse donc à la république qui
s'était quelque peu égaré magnifique
discours en l'honneur des d'emile zola
et de son combat pour la république la
justice contre toutes les formes
d'intolérance de discrimination
prévu à proximité de la maison zola un
musée dreyfus devrait ouvrir ses portes
en 2018
politique toujours avec cette fois ci le
party les républicains qui a inauguré sa
nouvelle permanence départementale à
jouy en josas une permanence afin de
mieux préparer évidemment les prochaines
échéances électorales et notamment la
primaire de la droite fin novembre nous
avons rencontré à cette occasion le
président des républicains des yvelines
david douillet également député et
conseiller régional il nous parle de ce
rendez-vous des primaires et de cette
nouvelle permanence qu'il souhaite
totalement neutre au micro d'haussmann
vendeurs des ces permanences
électoralement
impartiale voilà l'idée je ne tolérerai
pas aucune activité pour l'un ou pour
l'autre voilà c'est c'est la permanence
des républicains voilà tous les
candidats à la primaire sont
républicains et celle ou celui qui
seront élus le 27 novembre sera la
personne derrière laquelle tous les
africains vont se ranger pour gagner
cette présidentielle c'est très clair
donc ce message le dit dès aujourd'hui
le plus grave problème que nous
pourrions rencontrer au sein des
républicains c'est la division c'est les
plaies qui n'arrive pas cicatrisé donc
il ne faut pas occasionné de plaies
absurde voilà on peut avoir des avis
divergents partager mais en famille dont
discutent en famille mais la famille
reste la famille et quand il ya un
leader dans la famille on se met diary
sport à présent avec la 41e édition de
la ryder cup la plus grande compétition
de golf au monde qui voit s'opposer tous
les deux ans américains et européens la
dernière édition s'est terminée il ya
quelques jours dans le minnesota aux
états unis dans deux ans et 50 en
yvelines qui va accueillir l'événement
au golf national l'occasion de vous
faire découvrir l'envers du décor de
cette compétition avec michael et demi
d'euros
c'est un événement mondial suivie par
plus de 700 millions de personnes la 41e
édition de la ryder cup cette nuit du 30
septembre au 2 octobre à chaska dans le
minnesota
les meilleurs golfeurs de la planète
étaient présents sur les greens on
pouvait apercevoir l'icône américaine
tiger woods son camp le nord irlandais
rory mcilroy
le spectacle était également dans les
tribunes trois cent mille personnes ont
créé une ambiance digne d'un match de
football pendant la compétition
il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont déguisés
déguisé en voit beaucoup d'américains
mais on voit aussi des déguisements
européens ce qui est sympa à voir
également
c'est une pure atmosphère nous ne
pouvons pas la comparer à une ambiance
classique l'ambiance est comparable à un
stade de football
[Musique]
c'est la plus grande compétition le pays
la prend très au sérieux et nous sommes
très fiers de cette victoire de
l'indépendant directrice la ryder cup
capte également l'attention des médias
mille cinq cents journalistes venus du
monde entier ont été accrédités pour
assister à la compétition
je suis ici pour sky sports je m'occupe
des médias sociaux facebook twitter
instagram et je couvre ce qu'il se passe
en dehors de la compétition pour les
fans de la ryder cup je suis reporter
pour une chaîne de golf en chine c'est
ma première expérience sur une ryder cup
et je suis très excité d'être ici et de
veiller sur le plan économique plus de
150 millions de dollars sont engrangés
sur le site pendant les trois jours de
compétition
selon les chiffres donnés par les
organisateurs les visiteurs ont consommé
en moyenne entre 5 et 10 litres de
boissons sur cette ryder cup le panier
moyen d'un américain serait lui 200 $
dans les boutiques du site un impact
économique conséquent qui devrait
également se ressentir à saint quentin
en yvelines
d'après les études que nous avons
réalisées en impacts directs liés à
l'événement on aurait à peu près 150
millions de création de richesses et en
indirect qu'il faut rajouter à peu près
50% donc un total de 225 millions
d'euros de création de richesses sur un
événement qui est un événement assez
court puisque c'est trois jours de
compétition c'est très important la
ryder cup sera organisé en france du 28
au 30 septembre plus de 60000 personnes
devraient venir chaque jour au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
pour assister à cette compétition
mythique et d'ici 2018 les passionnés de
golf pourront éventuellement se rendre à
la ryder cup en autolib près d'une
trentaine de stations de véhicules
électriques vont voir le jour va voir le
jour excusez-moi 51 10 2017 après le
chesnay ou encore versailles il sera
donc possible d'utiliser ce mode de
transport dès l'an prochain à travers
les 12 communes de l'agglomération les
négociations sont toujours en cours avec
la société autolib selon nos confrères
du parisien le coût s'élèverait à 60
mille euros par station les premières
autolib à sky arriveront d'ici l'automne
prochain et c'est une parfaite
transition pour revenir avoue daniel
guerreau quel est votre point de vue
justement sur sur les autolib est-ce que
c'est justement l'une des solutions on
évoquait tout à l'heure le problème
entre les transports qui manque en
grande région et puis les pouvoirs
publics qui cherche à lutter contre
l'automobile est ce que ses voitures
électriques à disposition d'aidés
publiques c'est une solution selon le
mode chose ça fait partie de la
complémentarité organisé dans l'offre de
mobilité vous arriver en voiture où vous
prenez un bus vous sortez du bus vous
pour aider l'autolib pour nous ça ça
fonctionne très bien il n'y a pas de
souci alors les voitures électriques
autolib ça reste quand même assez
marginal en grande couronne tout l'art
vous avez rapidement évoqué des
solutions pour payet palier excusez moi
au manque de transports en commun en
grande en grande couronne et vous avez
dit notamment des parkings gratuits ce
qu'il ya d'autres solutions qu'on
pourrait mettre en place alors selon
vous les parkings gratuits gratuit
effectivement ça c'est une blague cela
la solution la plus importante et après
ce raid et parking gratuits aux abords
des gares par exemple routiers aux
abords des gares du rogas aussi aux
abords de la couronne parisienne parce
que quand vous arrivez à une porte de
paris moi je vais souvent à paris je
laisse ma voiture par exemple dans le
pas dans le parking de la porte maillot
si je la laisse une journée j'en ai pour
35 euros quelqu'un au smic ne peut pas
le prendre donc c'est pour ça aussi ça
dissuade les gens de laisser leur
voiture ça c'est une solution aux portes
de paris et après on prend les
transports en commun après il faut qu'il
soit bien organisé qui soient pas toutes
en panne qui ait pas trop de particules
comme dans le métro vous voyez des
parkings gratuits d'autres solutions des
financements c'était dans l'une des
enquêtes que vous avez mené vous allez
mener un référendum au mois de juin pour
pour demander aux internautes qu'ils
pensaient des mesures mises à paris par
inaki anne hidalgo et dans les solutions
évoquées il y avait le financement
deux systèmes antipollution pour les
plus vieux à emule c'est aussi une
solution qui est adoptée en allemagne
parce qu'on a beaucoup attaqué le diesel
là aussi il ya beaucoup d'
irrationnelles il ya beaucoup de
démagogie mais il yad'ailleurs confond
ce qu'on attaque de manière aussi
virulente les diesels en allemagne ils
ont aussi du diesel mais en allemagne
les vieux diesels ils ont choisi
d'offrir une solution alternative
traiter le problème en permettant un
financement pour mettre des systèmes
antipollution on appelle le retrofit qui
s'adapte sur les vieux diesels promesses
et le diesel c'est pas les nouveaux et
dont les allemands ont proposé je crois
que c'était 500 euros de primes pour
traiter les véhicules anciens voilà des
solutions intelligentes ici on commence
par tout interdire mais on traite pas
les problèmes puis ça fait un an pile
poil que le scandale volkswagen a éclaté
en allemagne en ce moment c'est le salon
de l'automobile a paru le plus grand
salon du monde quel est votre rôle à
vous dans ce salon est ce que vous êtes
présents sur place est ce que vous y
joue un rôle social aux dirigeants parce
que qu'ils achètent des automobiles ce
sont les automobilistes donc forcément
nous sommes présents nous rencontrons
tous monde de l'automobile et nous
voyons effectivement beaucoup
d'innovations d'ailleurs si vous écoutez
les médias on ne parle que de la voiture
électrique c'est vrai il y en a sur tous
les stands y en a un peu partout ceci
dit ça représente 1% des ventes 99 % des
ventes sont encore faites dans
traditionnel mais ont commis deux là
dessus donc il faut aussi prévoir
l'avenir dont l'électrique l'hybride ça
ce sont des solutions pour le futur les
l'hydrogène donc je crois qu'il faut
d'ailleurs si on regarde histoire
d'automobiles et décalée d elle a eu des
ennemis mais elle est encore là
presque deux siècles après ça veut dire
qu'elle a toujours su s'adapter à son
temps et je crois que la saint romain la
fin de l'automobile discussions demain
est extraordinaire outil de liberté vous
avez une enquête de cetelem qui est
sorti ya pas longtemps 90 % des français
sont attachés à leur automobile
81% aiment conduire donc entre ce que
les minorités nous disent et la réalité
de la vraie vie il ya une marge donc les
gens sont toujours attachés à
l'automobile et à leur liberté
contrairement à ce qu'on veut bien nous
dire mais il y aura des progrès qui vont
se faire il y aura moins de pollution on
aura même bientôt des voitures sans
accident moi j'ai essayé des voitures
sur autonomy beltoise à côté avec un
gros équipementier allemand on n'est qu'
on est chez des voitures quand il y à
vélo qui sort la voiture s'arrête tout
seul donc il ya des constructeurs qui
vous disent dans cinq ans je veux faire
une voiture sans accident elle va
pallier aux défaillances humaines on
referme ce journal avec une autre
actualité de la culture et le théâtre
alphonse-daudet de coignac accusé cette
semaine les tréteaux de france la
compagnie itinérante et centre
dramatique national joué le faiseur une
des rares pièces de théâtre de
l'écrivain français honoré de balzac une
oeuvre écrite en 1840 qui évoque les
dates et la spéculation un sujet
toujours d'actualité est un sujet de
mélanie poké le jugement supérieur
mais de voir
monsieur mercadier banquiers as de la
tromperie il gère l'insistance de ses
créanciers mais cette fois il est acculé
c'est le monde des affaires qui est en
train de naître à ce moment-là et
le monde des affaires des affairistes et
surtout moi si on joue beaucoup dans
cette pièce c'est toute la dimension qui
est très liée à
l'excitation du jeu en fait le faiseur
que jules bruno cadillon personnage
devenu marcadet donc s'appelle le
faiseur et sont les nôtres usa mais
c'était un grand joueur addictif on ça
parle de l'emprise ce qu'on peut avoir
sur les autres
[Musique]
adapté par évelyne l'homme est mis en
scène par robin renucci le directeur des
tréteaux de france le faiseur ces deux
heures d'une pièce millimétré et sans
temps mort une comédie grinçante ou la
composition d'acteur prend toute son
ampleur c'est une comédie particulière
parce que elle travaille sur plusieurs
genres qui à la fois du burlesque du
mélodrame da comédie de caractères la
comédie de situation dû presque du
masque cirque on est extrêmement
maquillé comme comme des masques avec
des perruques très particulière des
costumes aussi sont très marqués ils
sont trés dans le style à la daumier
spéculation tromperies mensonges et
manipulations plus d'un siècle nous
séparent de l'écriture et pourtant la
pièce semble intemporel il ya énormément
de matière dans le texte de balzac est
très riche qui est vraiment
extraordinaire il faut imaginer qu'il a
écrit en 1840 et que c'est un texte qui
est complètement moderne quand il ya eu
la ferme addow là il ya quelques années
le faiseur ils ont ressorti et est
marqué la ferme haddock écrite par
balzac en 1840 c'est pour dire comme il
était vraiment visionnaire avec de
l'énergie et du rocambolesque monsieur
mercadé n'a pas fini de nous interroger
sur un problème de société
les ans il ya l'automne créanciers
auraient tué l'année toutes ces
rubriques lancement
c'est la fin de ce set 8 hebdo merci
daniel guerreau de nous avoir
accompagnés pendant cette demi heure je
rappelle que vous êtes le président de
l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes merci à vous aussi de
nous avoir suivis bon week-end à tous et
à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]